Ilhan Omar facing backlash for comments
about the chaos in Venezuela the
controversial freshman Democrat now
suggesting that America could be partly
to blame for the uprising against
Nicolas Maduro socialist regime a lot of
the policies that we've put in place has
kind of helped lead the devastation in
Venezuela this particular bullying and
the use of sanctions to eventually
intervene and make regime change really
does not help the people of countries
like Venezuela and to be fair she did
gave another statement to Fox today and
I do think that we should play this
because she was trying to you know
explain more about what she thinks watch
the United States rule should be one
that is advocating for there to be fair
elections it should be one of guidance
and and technical support I don't
believe that interventions that are
pushing for regime change are in the
best interest of Venezuela and the best
interests of the American people okay
Jesse let me go to you the not in the
best interest of the Venezuelan people
to have regime change Wow
I just want her to say one good thing
about America just one I dish you a
challenge right now Omar please say one
good thing about America at least about
Jesse we hear her so much say what's
wrong with America just say what you're
proud of I think that would maybe
counterbalance some of the negativity
that you hear coming out of her mouth
also we should send a dictionary because
America is not bullying the people of
Venezuela
it's the Maduro and the russian-backed
military that are taking away people's
rights and shooting into the crowd and
doing all those things also this is what
socialists still when something good
happens in the world what they do is
they say oh why can't America be like
that country and then when something bad
happens in the world they say oh that's
America's fault that that's happening
but they can never cede the point that
socialism is failing on its own remember
what the Communists did after the Soviet
Union collapsed they said oh well
communism has never been perfectly
implemented or they did the same thing
with Obamacare Obamacare failed because
Donald Trump undermined it but at this
point I just want to I I want her to do
this stop siding with the Russians I
mean two years you say you want to start
World War three over the Russian
interference in the election now they're
interfering physically in our hemisphere
and you're siding with them but the
other thing is that the actual
Constitution in Venezuela was followed
and the recognized President Guido
recognized by 51 countries including the
United States they're following so he
Maduro is not even the recognized leader
of the country anymore right that so
what she's saying is our role should be
advocating for fair elections that's
exactly what we did we're advocating for
that fair election and where bullying
she uses the word bullying if we were
bullying at all you're bullying a guy
whose military tanks are mowing down
people in the street bullying the
bullies yeah exactly so somebody's got
to stand up for these people we talked
about how these people are in large part
in all part actually completely unarmed
they feel extremely vulnerable they feel
they're starving in the streets they're
digging through garbage for their food
I commend any country in any leader of
any country who bullies a leader who
subjects its people to that kind of
atrocity and Greig some people might say
that we're not doing enough to help them
some people might be me yeah you know
what's weird is like I mean she
positions herself as someone who is for
the underdog so she should be really out
in front for these people the people
that are being run over the people that
are starving they are the true oppressed
I mean I believe that see the thing is
her ideology exists independent of
politics or religion it's ingrained in
the hard left of the oppressor versus
oppressed ideology she always believes
that places like America are guilty of
imperialism of being the oppressor and
here is a situation where you actually
have people that are being oppressed but
all she sees is the Yankee imperialism
that is ingrained not from any religion
and us and also not really from any
politics but from our own academia this
isn't Muhammad's doctrine this is Bill
Ayers doctrine the breath the belief
that right the
radical believe that if you look at any
evil around the world America is at the
root but the one she might say that it's
based on her experience as a child and
that was in the refugee camp and then
she came to America and she just had a
different upbringing initially and when
she was very frustrated that the United
States was not she didn't think was
helping them enough that's an accurate
account but I think she's wrong on this
point I mean to me the United States has
a history of bullying interference in
Latin America you think about Nicaragua
you think about El Salvador and the kind
of unrest that we fomented they're quite
intentionally CIA very active but I
think in this case what you have is not
so much socialism Jesse as desperate so
I think that when you think of Hugo
Chavez when you think of Nicolas Maduro
or you think of the influence coming
from Putin coming from the Chinese as
well
these are despots who are trying to run
over Iran lots of deserving people it
doesn't mean they can't be both
socialism and this is totally separate
this is not like to do with socialist
rule this is about people who are cruel
indifferent leaders that's what my doing
how did they get there okay let me just
say if you want to talk about that then
you get to talk about big oil companies
coming in making deals running over
people big oil companies if not run this
country into the ground I think that you
should go do some studying because my
hand that they nationalized the oil
company in response to the abuses of big
oil but let's stop I don't think it's
worth going over but I do think it's
important to say that she's wrong and
that the reason for this collapse is
despotic behavior that needs to be
countered instead of supported by the
Russian Chinese we she's been wrong on
everything
okay so let's but the point is the
advice to wouldn't do Republicans about
Omar is the same advice I give to
Democrats about Trump if you have a
problem with her try to win the election
put somebody up against her and and beat
her at the at the voting booth because
she is motivated to me by some a lot of
anger and a lot of disdain